Traductor: Analia Padin
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Es el año 15 d.C. y el Imperio
romano está prosperando.
El emperador se llevará
casi todo el crédito,
pero este éxito no habría sido posible
sin soldados leales como Servius Felix.
Servius se enroló como legionario
hace ocho años, a los 18,
hijo de un agricultor pobre
con pocas perspectivas.
No juega a las apuestas como
casi todos los legionarios,
por lo que ha podido ahorrar
la mayor parte de su salario.
Hasta se ha guardado el viático,
las tres monedas de oro
que recibió cuando lo reclutaron.
Si sobrevive hasta que se jubile,
recibirá varias hectáreas de tierra.
Y se ha encariñado bastante
con una chica de su pueblo
con la que piensa casarse.
Pero para eso tendrá que esperar
hasta completar 25 años de servicio.
Y la vida de un legionario
es peligrosa y agotadora.
Hoy, la legión de Servius
junto con otras tres
ha llevado a cabo una "gran marcha"
de 30 000 pasos romanos,
el equivalente de casi 36 km.
La armadura y las armas de Servius,
incluyendo su "gladius",
su "scutum",
y sus dos "pila",
pesan más de 20 kg.
Y eso sin contar su mochila, o "sarcina",
donde tiene comida y las herramientas
que necesita para construir el campamento:
la pala,
la sierra,
el pico
y el canasto.
Aunque se encuentra exhausto,
Servius no dormirá mucho esta noche.
Le han asignado su primera guardia,
lo cual implica vigilar
los animales de carga
y mantenerse alerta
ante una posible emboscada.
Cuando termina, se queda despierto
temiéndole al día siguiente,
lo que lo hace pensar
en su peor pesadilla.
Al amanecer, Servius desayuna
con sus siete compañeros de tienda.
Son como una familia, todos con heridas
de las batallas que pelearon juntos.
Servius es de Italia,
pero sus compañeros vienen
de distintas partes del Imperio,
que se extiende desde Siria hasta España.
O sea que están todos lejos de casa,
en la región de Germania, al norte.
La legión de Servius
y otras tres que están hoy con él
están bajo el mando de Germánico,
el sobrino del emperador Tiberio,
llamado así por el éxito militar
de su padre contra los pueblos germánicos.
Cada legión tiene cerca de 5000 hombres,
divididos en cohortes de unos 500,
que a su vez se dividen en centurias
de 80 a 10 hombres aproximadamente.
Cada centuria tiene un centurión
que está al mando.
Un aquilifer, o portador del águila,
marcha al frente de cada legión
llevando el estandarte con el águila.
Los centuriones marchan
junto a los legionarios
gritando órdenes.
"Dex, sin, dex, sin",
"Derecha, izquierda, derecha, izquierda",
empezando con el pie derecho
ya que el izquierdo trae mala suerte.
Pese a la estricta disciplina,
se siente tensión en el aire.
El año pasado, algunas legiones
en la zona se rebelaron,
demandando mejor paga
y menos años de servicio.
Solo el carisma y la capacidad
de negociación del general
evitaron una rebelión generalizada.
Hoy es una "marcha corta" de solo 30 km.
Los pantanos y bosques de Germania están
fuera del sistema de caminos del Imperio,
así que los hombres deben construir
carreteras y puentes para poder avanzar,
algo que últimamente les ha insumido
más tiempo que las batallas.
Finalmente llegan a su destino,
un lugar que Servius conoce muy bien.
Es un claro en las afueras
del bosque de Teutoburgo,
donde hace seis años, durante
el reinado del emperador Augusto,
los pueblos germánicos
comandados por Arminius
les hicieron una emboscada
y destruyeron tres legiones.
Avanzando por un camino angosto,
las legiones fueron atacadas
desde el bosque bajo una lluvia torrencial
sin tener cómo salir.
Fue una de las peores derrotas
que hayan sufrido los romanos
y Augusto nunca lo superó.
Servius fue uno
de los pocos sobrevivientes.
Servius todavía tiene pesadillas
de sus compañeros caídos.
Pero ahora el ejército está de vuelta
para enterrar sus muertos
con honores militares.
Mientras ayuda con la tarea,
no puede evitar preguntarse si los huesos
que manipula son de alguien que conocía.
Muchas veces quiere llorar en voz alta,
pero sigue adelante con la tarea.
La gloria del Imperio
se la pueden quedar los cuervos.
Lo único que ansía es poder retirarse
a una pequeña granja con su futura esposa,
si los dioses le perdonan la vida
durante otros 17 años.